it looks like they abandoned the plan of
uh
basically capturing the big cities and
they just trying to push into kiev and
capture the president and most likely
assassinate him and to install a new
government and they do believe that you
know
assassination dolinsky will actually
change the perspective for the narrative
of the
resistance in ukraine i don't know i'm
just shocked that the world is standing
by they cannot even cut them out of the
swift code which is not even going to
damage that hard russia
and it's not that hard to do and you
europe cannot even do that they cannot
even close our airspace so the airships
would not attack us from the air so that
our troops would have a fighting chance
to actually defend ourselves
there's not much need to be done
the biggest problem is that once they
capture ukraine
who's going to be next
you still have family there your mum's
there i think your brother's there have
you spoken to them
what are they doing are they hiding i
mean what are they doing to stay safe
my father is a professor of urology
so he does what he does
he goes to work
same as my brother
so they're trying to carry on
it's okay take your time
if you could get back and you had to
would you fight
of course that's the only reason i'm
coming back
you would fight even though you're a
tennis player
the army opened up the reserves and
everybody who's willing to fight
to come in and collect the weapons and
to be part of the territorial resistance
there's plenty of people in them uh
i've actually signed up for reserves uh
last week i left here from saturday i
just didn't have enough documents to
sign the contract there's going to be a
lot of support for ukraine um
in football you know this weekend it's
been approved that if players managers
want to show the ukrainian flag
they can
um
does that make any difference it makes a
world of difference to our
arms forces i would say
seeing that they're not left alone at
least
no
in the media environment but let's be
realistic here it's been eight years of
the war since russia whether it was
russia proxies or russia itself it
doesn't matter where was all of this for
eight years none of us believe that it's
going to happen
and
yet it happened and none of
them i mean the european leaders all the
world is ready to have ready to help
ready to put
the fight
in ukraine
for maybe a better europe in the future
we want to be a normal civilized country
with democracy where you can actually
elect your president and as far as i can
go i can say that
today the president we have is most
likely the only president which we ever
had in terms of standing for his country
and believing what he does and risking
his own life
the only one
all of them before were just a political
jokes
they were political jokes he may be a
comedian in life but he's become a
president for people